Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome to little bug..
Oookayy..
Am I supposed to usd a gamepad or can I  use a keyboard for this one?
Now this is just a demo of a game that's
either upcoming or I-I don't know how old the demo is so it might...
oh...
woah...
I don't know what just happened
but it was magical and I love it. (Of course you do Mark)
I'm.. I'm... oh.
Can I jump?
Ooooookaaaayyy...
Woah...
Oh, that's cool! (Cool Count:1)
Okay, so... *leaves*
I  might need a gamepad for this one.
Okay, so I gotta control them independent- wow, that is...
That is sensitive, and also
uh... did something happen
there- there's a rather sinister connotation to this
and I'm not sure what the hell is going on here...
but it seems that you just got in a car accident.
*reads* "Right bumper"
Oooooh!
Oh, that's cool! (Cool Count:2)
That- that's really cool! (Cool Count: 3)
Weeeeeee!
Yeah!
Oh, that's so cool! (Cool Count: 4)
Ohhh, I love it! *Mark bounces up and down*
I love it a lot! (He really loves it)
Ah, okay, anyway, so carrying on...
Beside for my ability to- whoa
That could've been instant death or probably not,
I doubt that they would've killed this
what I can only assume it's a little child...
I don't know.
But this is awesome, I love the way the light works!
It's so cool! (Cool Count:5)
It's one of those cool things that I'm gonna say is cool a lot. (Cool Count: 7)
Okay, so what was the point of going down here?
Am I supposed to fall through?
Weeeeeeee
Oh, boy!
Jaunting into the unknown!
Forever and ever and ever.
Oh.
Oooh.
Aaaah... *Mark finds something out*
Oh, that'll break it instantly, okay.
So, I- I think that was the lesson it was about to teach me right here.
Wabooshky!
Whoop, not high enough.
Okay, hang on.
Little longer...
Wa-bam!
Okay.
So, can I jump?
Can I- uh.
Who needs to jump when you have a magical fairy following you around?
It's my version of Navi.
Oh, I see.
Can't fool me, I got it!
Man, this is some intri- it's-
it's fascinating mechanics here
there's some really cool stuff at play. (Cool Count: 8)
Weeeee
Ah, see?
Bam! And right to the woods! (Cave Mark, you're out of the cave)
I don't know what kind of mystical demon put those magical barriers there,
or why you have magic inside of your soul,
but it's a fascinating experience and I can't wait to see more of it.
But sadly this is another game where it's just a demo,
I've been playing a lot of this demo games
and I want the full versions!
I want it all!!
Oh, give it to me!
Hello...
Hi, I just noticed you in the background.
This must be some kind of magical world,
because I don't know why that would be...
just freely allowed to roam around!
But that seems like it might be some kind of bad...
My- my first instinct is bad. (Team Instinct ftw)
*Reading* Trail Closed?
To who?
Don't you know who I am?
Even I don't know who I am.
Wabooshky!
Wee
Well, that didn't quite work.
I think I was on the right track...
Okay...
Ha, you think a moving puzzle is gonna be any sort of a- oops.
is gonna be any sort of a problem for me?
Uh, I think not...
What's with the flower?
Oh, press X! *Mark presses X*
*reads* Wild flowers are the prettiest.
Yeah!
I guess!
And I- WOOOOAH.
Hey, grabby hands!
Eugh...
That's a... that's really sinister.
Why?
Oh man, that's- that's liter-
OOOOOH MY GOD, SHE EXPLODED!
He?
I don't know? I can't tell!
Oh, man.
Well, I gotta watch the momentum on swinging this poor child!
This...
Navi, suddenly regretted
when her
her ward exploded on her.
*reads* Press X... I wonder who this belongs to.
I don't know!
Oh, wait, did I not pick up the other thing?
Wait, I didn't pick up the other thing, goddammit I gotta go all the way back.
I'll Hopskotch it
Weeeee
woooo, ahahaha
I found a secret!
There we go.
Okay...
I don't know...
why that didn't go before...
Hop!
Ohh. OOOH, NO!
GODDAMMIT, I thought I was skilled! (Mark pls)
Oh, well, I appeared there anyway so I guess it's all good...
Wabooshky.
Woops.
NOO! AHHH!
Okay, we're fine!
Oooh!
So, that can't touch that...
eeeeither...
hehe.
Ohhh, I went right into it!
Right into it!
Okay, this...
Now we're getting complicated!
Heh!
Nooo, okay, almost did it.
Woah, grab hands.
Ooh, grabby grabby grabby, no no no!
That's a bad grabby!
Wooo, wooo, wooo!
Oh shit.
We're down. We're here!
Sorry.
*reads* A wild fungus. My favorite!
*incoherent mumbling about shrooms*
That's possibly insinuating that this kid might've been doing drugs but then again,
I don't know...
I don't know if this is actually a child at all...
I- aaaaahhh she exploded!
he, I don't know, I can't tell.
Hop!
Okay.
So what I gotta do is I gotta walk down and then...
Right here.
YEEEAAAH- OOOOOH
Sail right into the abyss!
My goodness!
There we go, a little more!
Conscious-like
Hop!
There we go!
That's less death.
Oh boy!
Is that a spider?
I bet that's your favorite as well!
Weee, cool, a spider!
Oooh!
It looks so happy in my little terrarium here.
Oh, no, it's crying!
Oh, boo-hoo!
Ah, shit.
Is it crying over my death?
Probably.
Eh, eh,eh!
Wahaha!
Ahaha!
I've got the skill!
And the power.
And the thrill!
He, he.
Okay.
No! That didn't go as I planned it.
Fuck.
Egh!
Aaaaah, explosions!
Explosions of the me.
Fudge!
*sings nonsense*
Yeah, I wouldn't have been able to do this with the keyboard, this would've been...
Very, very, very difficult.
Okay, hang on.
Heh, eh, okay we got it!
No, hang on.
*Mark concentrates very hard*
There we go!
Get along, get along, get along, go go go go!
Yes!
*reads* Don't be sad, I found a pretty rock! ｡◕‿‿◕｡
Ooh!
Oh, okay, you mean a priceless gemstone, probably...
*singing nonsense again*
Whoops!
Ah, shit!
So I need to go up!
This is gonna be haaaard...
Hop!
Okay.
Eh, hop!
Eugh.
Egh, oh, oh
Oh YEEAAH!
YEEAAHH!
Oh, come on!! I was just-
I- I couldn't do the thing?
Haaa, haa!
Oh, rest.
Haaa!
Oh, oh, AAAH
AAAHHH
GRABBY HANDS...
This is gonna be hard. (That's what she said Mark)
No, don't look at that.
I don't care about that.
"How could you say you don't care about that?"
*Mark's "I'm concentrating" sounds*
Oooooh YES!
*reads* Wow, mama's favorite flower.
Okay.
What I- what I question is whether now, wether all this is a fever dream
because it seemed like...
she was in a...
a car accident of some- oh.
Oooooh.
Oh, okay.
Goodbye!
Where did I go..? (Where did you come from Markijoe)
My firefly is gone now, I miss it very dearly.
Where did it go?
Ooooooh, hiiiiii..!
How are yooouuu..?
Oho.
Oh, okay.
Oh, you've got a lovely smile.
I'll just be on my way over here- well.
Apparently...
And that's the demo, that was amazing!
I loved that!
That's really cool! (Cool Count: 9)
I want more!
Gimme gimme gimme!
I can't wait!
Oh, boy boy!
I want to see more of that.
I really really do.
I really, really do.
That was cool (Cool count 10)
Great concept,
great game mechanic,
I love it a lot,
challenging, cool art style, (Cool Count: 11)
all the above.
So, either way!
Thank you everybody so much for watching,
check out this game through the link in the description below,
and as always,
I will see you,
in the next video!
Buh-bye!